- So my nectar love print is R W E G
which means I have a
reflective communication style.
I am a we person.
I prefer emotional intimacy
and I'm guarded like a lot.
- I am a bodybuilder.
- I'm a bodybuilder.
- Why don't we cycle through?
Why don't you say who your favorite Mr.
Miss Olympia was, how many
titles they won and why
you kind of preferred their
physique or their kind of Mr.
Olympia or Miss Olympia
over everyone else?
- Probably Dorian Yates.
I don't remember what
year exactly he competed
but Dorian Yates is probably one
of my favorite bodybuilders.
- How many times did he win the oath?
- Dang, that's a good one.
I don't know.
- But you should know that
if he's your favorite guy.
- I don't, I don't,
- That other dude, he's way older than me.
He knows about way more stuff than me.
So when he is asking
these questions, I'm like,
dog don't know.
- Got horrible DOR Yates fan.
The hell kind of Dorian Yates fan are you?
If you don't know how
many times you won the out
- You know what color his skin is?
- Yeah, of course.
- What color is he?
- Little light skin.
- Light skin guy?
- Light skinned.
- I don't know what you
want me to say, I mean,
- Light, light skinned
black guy or white guy?
- I'm not black white guy.
Light skinned white guy.
- Light skinned white guy.
Gotcha.
- I'm not as big as Ronnie
Coleman, but you know
I'm trying to get there though.
- I would say the same for Ronnie.
- I was prepared to answer that.
So it was one, two and then
he was about to get to me
and then homeboy on the end
decided he was gonna cut me
off and answer the
question before I could.
- I was under the impression
that everyone had to
answer the question cause
I don't think she did.
- I got a question for everybody.
Yeah. How many times a
week do you go to the gym?
- I go to the gym 10 times
a week, six days a week.
- Usually as a buddy builder
the most important thing
besides food is actually resting
and you only grow when you rest.
So I thought it was overdone.
- That don't sound right,
but I just went with it
cause I know body builders can go
to the extreme sometimes
when it comes to working out.
- I go to the gym five days a week
and then I do things outside of the gym.
On the sixth day
- I work out five days a week
with weights and every day with cardio.
- And that is time. 5 minutes is up.
(buzzer sound)
- So there was a tie which means
there'll be a 60 second tie breaker.
So two that were voted were Dhillon
and Juwan.
- Damn man.
All right.
Okay man.
Right. I've been body
building since I was 14 outta
high school.
I've competed in three
body building competitions.
I did two at the beginning of this year.
The first one Muscle contests
and the second one was Fit
World.
- Been body building for
a little over a year.
Always worked out.
Won the
My first competition was the
Muscle Beach last September.
(buzzer sound)
- Damn.
Dude I was so it is what it is
- In the gym.
name kind of one quirky thing
that you do like in the gym.
Like for me, I'll start
like maybe, I don't know
some days like when it's leg day
you have like a certain pair of shorts
or a certain pair of
pants you like to wear
on leg days and those
are your leg day pants.
- I don't do a thing that's quirky.
I do things cause others can't.
- You know, his body
brothers, you know, we usually
have a lot of, you know,
little superstitions kind
of habits that we follow,
patterns, things like that.
- Talking from a woman's
perspective, we try not to wear
you know, bras like we
just wear the sports bras
but not the specific
ones because they break.
You ever had something like that Jenna?
- You know what, actually, yes, I have
but I still wear them and I
my quirky thing that I like
to do is I, I like to come
to the gym and at our gym
pretty much everybody is
in great shape and fitness competitors.
So I like to pick out one person
on that day and just kind of
just watch what they're doing
and then go and ask
'em what they're doing.
- We don't have time to talk to people.
We are too busy doing our thing.
- I mean, not necessarily
on the weight floor
but I need extra help
and motivation, cardio.
So I go up, do my cardio
and see who's who I can beat
and try to keep up with that person.
- Whenever I do cardio
I actually watch a full day eating like
like muk bangs and whatnot.
I don't know why.
Especially when on contest prep
I just like watching on people eat.
What's your guys' favorite exercise?
Equipment and brand.
- Prime
- Prime?
- Prime Equipment.
- All the way, man.
- I think especially like with a lot
of the new stuff they have is Arsenal.
- I used to go to Coliseum with Milo.
Serge was, and they had really like all
and they had no fan and all machines.
- You went to Coliseum?
- Yeah, Milo's room?
- That was amazing.
- How about this?
If, if we're all comfortable with it
name at least two compounds
you'd run pre-contest.
- What do you mean least are
- We, If you don't know what
I mean, you must not be my
- I'll plead the fifth
- Toward the end.
You might expect something
like a halo and something
that doesn't aromatize.
Like maybe a trembelone
- This past contest I just
my first time running test or this
past competition season.
- How about you?
- Maybe thing Ava Winster
HEH, lesteron primo, the whole thing.
- Suss primo.
Matron clin.
- You're on sus pre contest.
- Oh yeah.
- Okay.
- It works right for me.
- You're not doing it Jenna?
- I'm sorry
- You're not taking
- I'm just, because I don't want
I I prefer not to say it
just because of the Yeah
- I'm not admitting, I'm
just saying I'm not admitting.
I'm just saying it.
- Yeah, I I'm not asking
anyone to admit anything.
You just, what would one
- But have to be careful.
- Clash divisions.
What are y'all?
- Men's physique
- Womans bodybuilding
switching to physique.
- Well, if you do physique
you must not be a
bodybuilder by definition.
- Uhoh
- Just saying
- You don't how many classes than a woman.
- How big are you calves?
- 16 inches.
Anything else?
- All right, we were tied again.
And the two people that
were picked again was Jwan.
- They're just kinda
trying to kick me off.
- And the second person is Jordan.
- First of all, I can't even believe
that you think I'm a liar,
but I, I am body building.
I live the, the grimy
lifestyle of body building.
- I have no reason to lie.
I mean my 619 square
foot apartment is at Gym.
(buzzer sounds)
- I didn't know what to
really, what to expect
but I feel like I don't
typically act like bodybuilders.
So it was an overall good experience.
- If you guys think that
you have successfully
voted the liar out
we can stop playing right now.
Whether or not you won.
if you think the liar is still
among you guys, raise your hand.
to say you wanna keep after count three.
Okay. 1, 2, 3.
- The majority of you
believe that the liar is out
which means the game is over.
- If the box is green, you guys are good,
if it's red, then the liar is still there.
- You want you want us to
take our blindfolds off?
- Damn
. Second guess that.
- The liar has won game.
- 1,
2,
3.
- You know, I really came
in thinking that, you know
we'd be able to mole out the liar
but I guess they were prepared
they were somewhat
integrated into the industry
so it made it a little bit harder to kind
of rattle them out.
- I said I was right.
I I voted her, she was out.
I knew she was the liar.
I was the only one who voted.
Right? Am I tripping?
Or who else voted for her?
Y'all was getting on me.
What color Dorian is?
- But she didn't answer the damn question.
- No, I know.
That's why I
was like, I don't know the answer.
I don't know the answer,
I'm pleading the fifth.
- Yeah, but that, that
if you allowed me more time, I was gonna
I was going to pick her apart,
but I just wasn't able to
- I actually do work out six
days a week, which is I work
out with a coach and I'm 50,
so I was like, you know what?
I'm keeping up with the Kardashians.
I really do wanna compete.
Believe it or not.
Before I go, where can I go?
Oh, snap, there's money.